hello folks how's everybody
welcome to rational science
and i was looking at some of the
comments there looks like people are
already fighting
we haven't even started and they were
already fighting
uh today we're going to be doing the
taurus
doris what the hell is a taurus
well uh before we can get to the taurus
and find out what that is
uh let's do a little bit of extinction
another
popular subject in this site and we're
gonna start what
with the taurus we're gonna start with a
stanford
taurus this was an idea concocted uh
in 1975 originally and they designed
this thing that
people can live in uh looks like that
like a taurus okay uh
donut because that's the best
description you can give it
the analogy and it looks like that
uh so inside it
it looks uh with it's got this river
water there it's got um
living space it's got highways it's got
airplanes going in there you know the
whole works it's
supposedly like here on earth except
that you know
it's round and it turns right
it's about 1.8 kilometers
in diameter and about 5.6
kilometers all around which is about
three and a half miles
okay and uh supposedly it holds
ten thousand people it can house ten
thousand people
and it would do farming in about i think
it was if i read it correctly a
while back since i've read that about a
third
of the taurus is living space another
third
is agriculture uh land etc
and i can't remember what the other part
was the i guess
cattle or whatever and so the issue is
you know living in space will we build
such a monster it weighs like 10 tons
also
will we build such a monster and live in
space ever
is is this the way to avoid extinction
or going into space and
you probably heard of the idea but let
me just mention it you know one one
possibility here
that comes to mind is that you know you
can travel
intergenerationally on one of these
things supposedly
right or that's the idea that's the
proposal the theory
uh you can travel on one of these things
you send ten thousand people on one of
these
uh cylinder not cylinder
toruses right donuts and you send them
to another star system right you send
them the alpha centary
after verifying that there is a planet
where we can live
right maybe third rock from the sun over
there or from
alpha centauri or beta centauri or
whichever
and so we we already scouted it we
already
know about it we sent our robots there
they looked it or maybe they even
terraformed this land
fine great now it's it's uh
humans turn to go there okay and it's uh
4.3 light years
one way that means if we could travel at
the speed of light it would take us 4.3
l
years to get there one way um
you know not to mention that we can't
travel at that speed so
we'd probably go a lot slower maybe
the best we can imagine today uh
technology today is ten percent of that
and that's again with far-fetched
technology and so we would get there
in uh assuming you know in uh maybe
40 years 40 plus years maybe between 40
and 50 years
assuming we could travel at that speed
right uh
and so the question is how do we get
there well one way is uh with
this intergenerational thing where we
send a taurus
people are born people die right
new generations come up and airborne
they die and
new generations come up and so on down
the line
and uh 50 years down the road we finally
reached destination not us not the
people who love
but their grandsons are great grandsons
okay
that's that's maybe the best notion you
can imagine
uh what is the problem with that well
one problem you got to consider
is that the farther you go from the sun
uh the less the sun uh powers your
your little ship there so uh
think about that you know the farther
you get uh the less
energy you get from the sun same thing
happens also with um for those of you
who are
uh are familiar with it the light sail
okay you got this
little ship which is about one kilogram
with a sail the size of turkey
the country of turkey and the sun can
push it at
approximately a tenth of the speed of
light
okay which would be about 30 000
kilometers per second
but that's here in the neighborhood you
know i mean the farther it goes
outside of the uh solar system
well you know that solar wind can't push
that sail
uh at the same speed that was here in
the uh
in the solar system within the solar
system and you know for that
you got to look at uh my video there
it's
known as the pioneer anomaly i analyze
that
gives you an idea that you know we'll
never get out of the solar system
and life cannot travel
interstellarly not at distances such as
four
light years away you know now uh
you know you have alpha beta and proxima
centauri
they're in the same neighborhood it's a
three-star system well
maybe they're close enough to each other
where
if there is life they could conceivably
you know go to another planet within
that three-star system
but us here we're so isolated from
everything
uh no there's no way life can come here
or life can go here
so all these people who talk about
panspermia
they have no clue what they're talking
about you know uh
it never happened not here on earth
maybe some other planet
where we have close enough stars you
know binary stars or
triple stars like alpha centauri
otherwise uh no it can't happen we can't
have panspermia we can't have
living things come here and visit us
it's impossible
physically impossible and for that you
got to look at the
pioneer anomaly that's where i've got
that argument anyways
uh will we travel ever
to another star i say we won't and if
that's
correct if that's a good assessment what
the hell we spending all this money
in research for
colonization and i want to clarify i
have no problem with
understanding that governments would
like to have
um uh research done
for military purposes okay that i can
understand
what i can't understand is that they
would
give money for colonization
okay for people going out there and
populating mars or the moon or
some other stone you know can that ever
happen
and if it can't happen what the hell are
we spending the money
for tourism i can also understand you
know we have elon musk
he's uh spending his money maybe to
carry people around for a week rich
people who can pay
uh to go out there for one week around
you know the earth a little bit in outer
space
great adventure no problem there either
but colonization
that's something else you know are we
going to evacuate the earth
send everybody to mars smaller planet a
fourth the size of
the earth approximately um
are we going to terraform are we going
to do all that effort for what
we have enough space here on earth at
this point
we got a long ways to go and if
extinction has its way well we'll never
make it beyond the earth so
what's all this money being spent for
and it turns out they um
they did all kinds of studies
on whether humans can live in space you
know because again
people are thinking of colonization and
it was a project uh
started in the around uh
1975 i think also but it
uh it was finally completed by
around 1991 and it turns out i went
there it was in near tucson
arizona a little north of tucson
and it's known as biosphere 2. and these
are the people
eight people four women and four men who
lived in there for about
i think three and a half years and i
went there almost
shortly after it was open and i saw them
you know doing what you see there
they're
they're attending the the cattle
the chickens and whatever they've got in
there and uh
and they were also working in the garden
and so on
and the idea was to be self-sustainable
okay produce their own food
it's hermetically sealed you got to go
in there through
locked doors you know special kinds of
doors that
will not allow any atmosphere to leave
or any atmosphere to come in
and they lived there for all uh
quite a while and uh you know they they
did all kinds of experiments especially
trying to figure out if uh if they could
live there
in other words they decided to uh to go
to prison
voluntarily for three and a half years
uh and again to learn whether humans can
live
in a an environment for example in outer
space
for example in the taurus right in the
stanford taurus
if they could you know live there and
there were all kinds of problems among
them you know
apparently there was uh more co2
being kept in there than
o2 i guess the plants were not absorbing
all the
co2 they were supposed to and so
that was one problem uh another problem
was psychological you know i guess they
started
getting into a few arguments after a
while it was like
marriage they couldn't stand each other
so they had quite a few problems then
and it was a
at least a good study in that sense
right
and yeah uh you know the question is
humans like
to go to all these extremes and test
them out research
find out if we could you know live in
such an environment for example live in
outer space
uh one of the things that they're
considering one of
some of the factors that they're
considering for when humans go
to mars assuming we get there right is
that you know it's a long trip
you're talking about maybe two years and
one of the issues is you know what
happens if you get a uh
appendix uh problem you need an
operation
so one of the suggestions was that all
these people had to have an appendix
operation before they leave
earth okay things of that nature
uh the other one was you know
psychological can they stand each other
will
one guy go nuts up there you know after
two years and
start killing people or whatever you
know so
there's several issues that they have to
consider before sending humans to mars
okay and so this is a good uh
way of testing a lot of that stuff find
out you know what kind of problems they
run into
okay and so okay so those are
some of the things you got to ponder if
you're if you're a uh
what is it a star trek buff will we
uh go to mars will we go with a tour
will we ever build a taurus
can we live in a taurus what kind of
problems can we encounter
uh with living in in you could say in a
in a
prison in a way it's a prison right
and you do have you know the sky lab up
there you have uh this uh
lab that's orbiting the earth and
astronauts take turns and they live
quite a while several months up there
you know there's the gravitational issue
they lose bone mass etc you know
physical things
but there's also the issue of
mental you know these people might go
nuts up there
and so they test all these things they
they really select their people and
train them uh hypnotize them or whatever
to to make sure they can withstand that
that entire environment it's not so easy
to say oh i'll just go into space how
nice you know
well there's a little more than nice
it's even worse than going to prison
you get stuck in a little room and
that's it you're
like in solitaire up there okay okay
some of these people uh later on the
people who went into biosphere 2 they
took a trip around the world
in their uh little ship known as the
heraclitus
and again they do research to find out
you know
uh what kind of environmental problems
there are they meet called
different cultures they they look at
certain things and they
make reports on on what they find they
also
learned a lot of shipment ship okay
how to run a ship and how to fix it and
all the types of problems they run into
and again the
the notion behind this is this notion of
spaceship earth
you know of uh being able to live
out there in space like we live on earth
is that the future of humanity will we
have a bunch of tauruses uh orbiting the
earth or whatever planet
and uh or the sun and uh
people living in there you know ten
thousand people and one taurus ten
thousand another hey i gotta visit my
grandma so uh
i'll just take the uh next uh flight to
the next taurus
right is that is that how we're going to
live uh jetson society so to speak
i don't know uh it was uh
conceived in 1975
we haven't built a single screw
yet for uh or both you know for
for such a an undertaking it's just uh
an idea fancy idea it's on paper
it's not out there uh will that ever be
built i don't know
but here we have an organization that
started around the same time
uh it was initially kicked uh started by
verner form brown who was the guy who
ran the rockets
for the united states after he was
enticed to go from germany to the united
states okay he ran the uh
rocket program and
they created this what it's called today
national space
society and this is what they believe in
they say we believe that space
development
settlement will occur most efficiently
and humanities prosperity will be best
insured if
and here they have the main points that
they have in their uh
goals okay and it's uh every human being
is given the freedom of thought and
action every human being is allowed
the opportunity to travel live in our
work in outer space
every human being is allowed the
opportunity to own property in space
or in other worlds
the free market drivers of competition
profit are used
okay so capitalism uh
rampant capitalism sounds like it was
written by uh
one of these narco caps okay
anarcho-capitalists
that's what this all looks like okay
national governments fund the research
and development of space technologies
deemed too high risk by their industries
uh nations cooperate on space research
and development and leave competition to
individual companies the fundamentals of
democracy are applied to and
incorporated by space settlements
and one of the goals and benefits of
space development and settlement is to
restore
and enhance the biosphere of the planet
earth
okay so uh again you can see we have
that biosphere that
taurus out there that's the idea behind
all this
and space development and settlement is
pursued in a manner
that safeguards alien life forms we have
to respect the aliens right
natural wonders and historical monuments
will any of this ever happen
is this just dreamers uh
people who have dreams and
their dreams take them you know a foot
off the ground
they're floating in air is this real is
this ever going to happen
well you know i'll tell you how i got
into this subject of extinction
and you know i used to believe also at
one time
without analyzing i just believed in him
without any reason to believe that you
know humans were going to
conquer the planets i thought it was a
logical conclusion there you know
yeah people will terraform like mars and
so on and from there jump
to another star system eventually and
from there
conquer the entire galaxy and then maybe
several galaxies you know that's the way
i looked at it
and i never gave it any thought i just
believed in it
without any reason it just seemed
logical to me you know
and then i started getting into this
subject of extinction really
through relativity because the relative
is you know all these
bozos out there they believe that humans
are gonna live forever
and uh why because they believe too much
in technology
and they think anything is possible and
they make all those
impossibilities work through
four-dimensional
things or wormholes or black holes you
know they introduce all this magic in
there and they say oh yeah then anything
is possible
i could just go through a wormhole get
to the other side of the universe in two
seconds and
this is the way these people think and
so i started looking at that and say
hold everything well
you know i thought this was just going
to to another star system
and yeah i thought it was possible but
then when i looked at the
numbers the possibilities and so on when
i did a more
serious analysis i i rejected it right
off hand and i wrote about that in my
book in fact
but today well i laugh at this there's
absolutely no
possibility whatsoever physically first
of all the second we're about to become
extinct
so uh you know i don't know what these
people have going to their
being brains it's never going to happen
but this is what people believe and a
lot of people believe this
out there simply because it's been
you know shoved down their throat by
authority they believe it on the basis
of authority because the mathematicians
told them so
and no one really stopped to think in
any detail a lot of people have
most people out there haven't stopped to
think whether this is even
feasible you know they they take it for
granted that
humans can do anything they want and
this is the way they think
and that's incredible and yeah so uh
what can i say anyways uh
moving on here uh one person asked a
question
or made a comment he says uh hey bill
uh would it be possible for you to
comment on jay hansen's overshoot
loot hypothesis in your amicable style
uh here is the link to the website etc
okay
now you know i did cover jay hansen
a while back i learned the other day
that he died
he had an accident a diving accident of
some kind
and uh yeah i wrote about him anyways
here it is here's the page
where i wrote about him in you
stupidrelativist.com for those of you
who are aware of the site
and you can look it up uh there i put a
the link there
okay so you can copy it and just go
there if you're interested in finding
out
what i said about good old jay and uh
one of the articles that came out of
that site that he created which is known
as die off
okay if you look for die off you'll find
that's hanson's site
and in die-off uh the article that most
impacted me which
i loved a lot and i recommend anyone uh
should
that everyone should read it it's this
one okay
it's a site it's a it's an article
uh by david klein and
uh kieln i'm sorry no claim
uh and um it's uh about
reindeers that were introduced into st
matthews island
uh up north uh near canada
and an island out there near alaska
that's that region
and um after several years of monitoring
these reindeer on and off it wasn't like
very
scientific it was just they went to the
island every now and then every
couple years or whatever and they looked
at the reindeer and they found a lot of
reindeer
at one point they did a population count
of reindeer
and it had reached up to six thousand
and then the next time they went there
uh there were like 20 left there was
only one male
and like 19 females and they were all
pretty much
sick and ready to die
i think they managed to save them but
it's a great study in what is known as
density dependent birth rates
density dependence you should learn a
little bit about that and one way to
learn is through that article you should
i recommend strongly recommend that you
read it what happened to the reindeer
that was an actual case
anyways that was uh the article that
i liked the most of um the ones i saw
die off by hanson hanson's site
and this is what uh good old hanson
had to say okay essentially this is his
philosophy
regarding um what this fellow mentioned
you know the overshoot and it's got to
do with
energy okay and that's why you know i
i frowned upon a lot on jay hansen
because he tries to mathematize
something that has
no reason to be mathematized he says
energy is a key aspect of overshoot
because
available energy is always limited uh
by the energy required to utilize it
organisms are required by the second law
of thermodynamics to dissipate energy
powers energy dissipation
for a purpose and equals force-type flow
blah blah blah okay
organisms evolve they bias to maximize
fitness by maximizing power with greater
power there's greater opportunity to
allocate energy
to reproduction and survival and
therefore an organism that captures and
utilizes more energy than another
organism
any population will have a fitness
advantage
well when people talk about energy and
fitness uh
advantage and talk about opportunity to
allocate this energy
and talk about reproduction and survival
i know they have no clue whatsoever
okay and uh so you know i have
very little respect to people that bring
up those subjects in the in the
context of extinction and they say well
the inevitable overshoot eventually
leads to decreasing power attainable for
the group with lower ranking members
suffering first
and what they go what he goes through it
here is
the new world order kind of thing you
know like saying the rich will
it will try to dominate the poor
essentially that's his argument
so uh all these people like hansen
they talk about peak oil they talk about
energy
which has nothing to do with anything uh
they talk about
the rich and powerful how they're gonna
conquer the world and
enslave all the poor people that sort of
thing
and that already turns me off
uh so let me let me just uh synthesize
here
okay here it is okay this is what these
people are they're environmentalists and
conservationists
and which are all my intellectual
enemies
okay uh these people have no clue
whatsoever anyone who's environmentalist
a conservationist has no clue whatsoever
why because they go off on tangents and
the
tangents are they talk about climate
change pollution overpopulation
endangered species crowding out of the
animals we're crowding them out
poaching zoo the entertainment the fact
that we use animals in zoos and circuses
that were slashed and burning the
forests and the jungles
uh were over foresting um
and peak oil and energy so
so the the issue here is that they get
go off on all these tangents and
some others that maybe i haven't even
mentioned and i had a
discussion with guy mcpherson and again
he believes it's going to be
an environmental catastrophe he gave the
date of 2026 as the last year for humans
uh he says that's when extinction is
going to hit us
we may not disagree on the date you know
i think it's
it's coming soon i can't say 2026. can't
say 2030 2022 i can't say any of that
because
i don't know i don't have a crystal ball
he put a date
but his reasoning his is the reason he
thinks
humans are going to become extinct is
for one of these
issues primarily climate change and the
fact that we are
abusing our environment where too many
people on the planet that sort of thing
okay and none of those have to do
anything with the extinction of man
okay in my humble opinion my theory okay
my theory says something different just
so that people are aware
that i'm not an environmentalist or a
conservationist
okay and here's comparison side by side
okay this is evil bill okay that's what
i have against these people
uh they take the discussion along your
relevant tangents
none of the issues that you see on the
left and others right
uh they raise cause extinction and none
of them
extinction has nothing to do with
climate change with overpopulation with
endangered species none of that uh mass
extinction
it's a food collapse and i have a
definition for that mass extinction to
disappearance of
a food chain that's what a mass
extinction is
one food chain goes away another one
continues on as if nothing
background extinction is the extinction
of a single species and it's caused by
what the overturning of the population
pyramid
okay the mass extinction is the
overturning of the ecological
pyramid in comparison in contrast
neanderthal woolly
you know these animals that we tracked
they died in a background extinction
they died all alone they died when their
population pyramid overturned
and they lost genetic diversity both
whammies at the same time
man we will not die in a background
extinction we
will be the last of the hominids
hominins whichever one you want to
call and we will die in a mass
extinction together with all the rest of
the mammals that are alive
today okay so
uh just so you know that um
we don't agree with some of these people
okay
uh let me get myself back in here if i
can find myself
give me a second
okay here we go ah
no we haven't gone yet
here i am i'm back okay
um so some people raise some
issues a long extinction let me answer
those questions or those comments
one person says here again uh
i think what ignorance says eventually
people will begin to flourish
you're you're acting like everyone is
just going to be
just going to go or going to be violent
okay we're all going to be violent just
kill each other
a small community of people can easily
begin to grow
lots of food okay and seriously life
will go on few chicks few dudes
more people in nine months
[Laughter]
poor valor ah i really feel sorry for
people who
who have no clue whatsoever in this case
because these guys will be the most
surprised when the
when the uh global economy collapses and
they'll find out that
their friends are not their friends okay
so uh
this is what the world population growth
rates look like
we're heading down uh to zero population
growth
somewhere this cent sometime this
century and together with that we have
loss of genetic diversity so even if a
pocket
of group of people survive this will not
be adam and eve
okay it will be um adam and eve
after you know they lost their genetic
diversity
so whatever kids they have after that in
a small population which has already
lost its genetic diversity
well all you'll have is six finger kids
autistic kids uh
homosexual kids you'll have all the
problems caused by
loss of genetic diversity which is what
we have today more or less
we're seeing just the tip of the iceberg
of what's going on out there
okay uh one another fellow says
i like this it says
every even the amish are armed
harmon a whole community comes down on
you
uh this guy's been watching too much tv
poor fellow he doesn't know
he doesn't have a clue i mean the amish
with guns this was a
a comedy that was uh on tv
in uh 2017 and they were just
uh you know making fun of the amish
there and this guy
probably saw a few photographs there
saying oh the amish aren't armed look
these are farmers that are armed amish
don't touch
weapons no matter how they don't even
touch a telephone
the the most dangerous weapon that a
an amish or a mennonite touches is a
plow
and they certainly won't use it to
defend themselves
completely unbelievable that people
really think that
uh they don't know they have no clue
okay now this guy has said it right the
guy with the guns and the will to kill
beats the guy with the food absolutely
this guy hit it on the nose yeah that's
the way it's going to be uh
those with guns will you know go
over the farms like the locusts you know
but it turns out that they don't even
need to
kill you or fight you you know think
about it for a second
you go to uh the world collapses
there's no more money there's no more
trade because the only thing of value is
food and you don't trade food
period we're done he would understand
that well he's got a mental problem
okay now there's no food so lots of city
folk will
rush to the country probably or a lot of
them will think about it
they'll go with their cars while they
still have gas okay
and they go to these acres and acres of
planted uh land us assuming
you know it's near harvest time you know
let us hope that when that happens there
we're close to harvest time okay so they
rushed to the uh
again one hemisphere is different than
the other hemisphere one hemisphere will
be in winter the other one in summer so
the guys in summer will probably be
better off than the guys in winter
okay but assuming you you're in the
world where it's summer still right you
go to the farms it's close to
harvest season and you see
all this you know the amber waves of
grain
just spreading out as far as the eye can
see okay
and you see all this uh all this grain
all this food
and you're hungry i guess what you're
gonna do well you might take your gun
with you but it's not because you take a
gun you take it maybe
just for defense but meanwhile you got
all these acres of land
you get one farmer in there is he gonna
control
you know 40 acres of land how's he going
to do it with an airplane uh
are you gonna run around with his car
people will just go to the farm and
start
tearing the corn whether at night or day
you know it's not a question of saying
oh i've got a gun so i'm going to defend
my my crops
well i want to see you defend you know
40 acres of crops or whatever
you know with your gun against thousands
of people who
are just hungry you know here you see
this kid
just eating corn because he's desperate
just starving
and you grab your gun you got to shoot
him in the head
yeah so
it's not a question of saying oh i'm
going to grab my gun and defend my land
no it's a question of first can you
defend it against thousands of people
who just
swarm your your farm because they're
hungry and they're just going to start
eating
or just taking the corn the wheat
whatever they can find out of the ground
and just
munching it raw you know
or grinding and turning into flour or
whatever
you know i don't think it's going to be
easy to defend against that
assuming you are a cold-blooded murderer
who just goes in there and
shoots people you know and are willing
to shoot people
to defend your land and what are you
gonna do go up there and say no folks
uh uh let's wait four months i'm gonna
teach you
how to grow food yeah
yeah we'll wait four months uh until you
train us
we we plant and we harvest yeah
sure now uh
when the [ __ ] hits the fan
it it's gonna be dog a doggy dog world
it's not going to be mr nice guy no way
and that's why all i can tell you is
whenever you if you want to address
extinction
do extinction 101 before you do 102.
don't tell me how man is not going to
die tell me how animals in the past
did die how they became extinct
and hopefully you don't come up with
asteroids volcanoes
and uh with supernovas or any of the
nonsense proposed by
paleontology today okay
okay okay let's move on to
artoris what the hell is a taurus
well um uh we
should start here really because uh what
we're going to find out is just like
we've covered what the um the circle
we covered the semicircle we covered the
sphere the square the triangle
we covered the tesseract the other day
which i'll go over one more time today
because there were some issues there
and then we get to the torus that we're
going to be doing today
what is all that about well it's a
geometric figure allegedly
okay but it turns out that this
thing called the taurus
is not really a geometric figure just
like all the others it's what
it's a bunch of itineraries
it's a bunch of locations and those
locations those itineraries
are swung around so in order to
understand because people think
that a torah is what you point to that's
a taurus a doughnut
no that's not what a taurus is not in
geometry
not in the religion of mathematics okay
in the religion of mathematics in the
religion of geometry trigonometry and
all that nonsense
okay a taurus is
an itinerary that is swung around
okay so you can't point to an itinerary
that is swung around you can't even
point to an itinerary
okay you're just pointing to a film of
whatever is
a bunch of locations that's all you're
doing and so a bunch of locations does
not in
a geometric figure make okay
so let's start at square one again
unfortunately i have to start at
square one to uh to look at the taurus
just like i did with the others and
where do we start well we start at the
point and the line okay and so here is
the uh
definitions we work out of objectively
from the definition i didn't invent the
stuff okay this is what mathematical
physics proposes
okay geometry etc trigonometry a
point is a primitive notion primitive
means undefined
it's an undefined notion that models an
exact location
that's what a point is it's a location
8.0 dimensional mathematical object
no there is no such thing as a
mathematical object a point is a zero
dimensional really
non-dimensional what location
it's a location there is no physical
entity called a point
now there is a physical entity called a
dot
okay you can point to a dot and if it's
a three-dimensional you call it a ball
for example
right it could be a cube but generally
people think of something round okay
fine it's either
a circle or a ball that's what a point
is
a line is a straight one-dimensional
figure no there is no such thing as a
one-dimensional figure they're talking
about itineraries they're talking about
locations
we have zero dimensional locations no
non-dimensional locations
uh one right after another building
constructing
what is known as a line and what is a
line it's an itinerary it's a trajectory
it could be an orbit if it's circular
okay
having no thickness no such monster
having no thickness meaning
just one dimensional again and extending
infinitely
no no no figure
uh known to man can even be imagined
imagine to extend infinitely there is no
table that is infinite
maybe god's table i don't know but
no table you can imagine no chair you
can imagine no tree you can imagine no
rock that you can imagine no
dog that you can imagine extends
infinitely
okay meaning incessantly because it's
still growing and still extending
okay in either direction for that matter
the notion of a line is usually left
undefined yeah they undefined it i'll
tell you why because they cannot
reconcile
the object known as line with the
concept dynamic concept known as
itinerary
you can't blend line with itinerary but
that's what they do they pictorially
represent the itinerary with a line
that's where the cheating comes in
that's cheating
that's misleading you because people say
okay i know what a line is it's that
stick
no no a line is not a stake not
according to mathematics mathematics
says it's an itinerary
and i'm going to enforce that i'm gonna
because that's how they define it so
don't tell me that it's a stick
there is no such thing as a stick in
mathematics they have no use for stakes
they have
used for itineraries you know
measurement unrolling
of the measuring tape that's what
they're doing here
that's conceptually and also by
definition i mean it's a straightforward
definition what part don't you
understand about
unrolling a measuring tape because
that's what they're doing
a line may be interpreted as a geodesic
what is a geodesic well supposedly the
shortest
distance between two points not like in
the old days you know a straight line
but on a curve
supposedly you can't cheat and take the
shortcut going straight
you know from one point to the other you
got to go around because supposedly
if you do it like on a planet like the
earth well you can't go through the
earth you go around the earth
around its surface and that's what a
geodesic is that's why the geodesic
became famous but then it's not the
shortest distance between
two points what it is it's the shortest
curve
curvilinear really itinerary between two
points
on a sphere that's the correct way to
state that not to say that's the
shortest distance between two points
you know and then leave it up to you to
figure out what did you really mean by
that i mean i can go right through the
center of the earth
and make it shorter if i can just cut
across the earth
okay i take any small
portion arc on the earth
and i'm sure i can go in a straight line
from one point to the other
faster than i can go through the curve
okay and i'm not going to prove that
it's just uh common sense okay we don't
need to prove that mathematically
okay um so this is what a point in line
are okay there you see it the
mathematicians
uh think that it's a turtle okay that's
uh leaving all these locations and
they're gonna call that
all the series of locations we're gonna
call that a line so line is not a stick
i want to make that point clear it's not
a stick what is a line
a bunch of locations what is a bunch of
locations an itinerary
of a turtle okay it's turtles all the
way
so let's keep in mind the context here
we're not talking about lines we're not
talking about
walls we're not talking about sticks and
we're not talking about
rocks or little balls or whatever no
we're talking about locations we're
talking about itineraries
that's what geo geometry deals with uh
this religion called geometry which is
an attempt to mix physics
with math okay and uh okay
so here uh we have uh what uh what
uh point and line are for the purposes
of physics
and in physics it's objective there's no
second uh guessing here
it's straightforward it's what you see
in front of you
okay so so you i'm not going to mislead
you
i'm going to tell you look what do you
see in front of you well the 2d point is
just
a circle it's a round one i'm gonna do
it with round
ones because that's what people usually
have in mind you know you put a chalk
against the board it leaves more or less
a circular pattern unless you got a
square chalk i guess
you know but um that's what it is it's a
circle
that's all it is and what is a 3d point
well a ball
how's that is that difficult so that's
what a point is
and uh we call it a dot
and if you're going to use the concept
location
don't call it a point because the point
is misleading because we don't know if
you're referring to the dot or to the
location by using the word point
if you're going to use location why
don't you do something radical and call
it
location how's that for uh
radical thinking radical uh uh
theorizing
and us assuming hypothesizing just call
it what it is
if you're gonna talk about location call
it location don't tell me point
because point is misleading what is a
line well it's a stick
that's what it is for the purposes of
physics we have two dimensional sticks
and we have three dimensional sticks
okay
and that's what a line is because that's
what's objectively in front of our eyes
okay in the case of the stick it's a
projection on onto
a two-dimensional background platform
right
um i can bring a stick and show you
what a line i'll say this is a line and
i can hold it in my hands and show it to
you get a three-dimensional stick
so we have a two-dimensional stick which
i can't show you i can only draw it
i can illustrate it which is typically
what is understood by the word line and
we have the three-dimensional state
that's what a line is for the purposes
of physics
okay let's make sure we understand
that's what it is for physics
okay okay some people have problems
with that they say well we have no use
for your 2d
and 3d point or through the 2d and 3d
line
of physics in geometry mathematics those
are some of the
issues people raise rejoinders etc okay
and this is our answer we don't care if
you can use them in math or not
that's what we have objectively in front
of us
okay so we don't care if you can use it
in math you we say
line and we refer to that thing that i
just showed you a little stick
and you say point and that's a circle
that's what it is a small circle you
want to do
a square fine no problem we have no
problem with you replacing the circle
with
squares or triangles or cylinders or
whatever you want to put in there i
don't care
as long as there's something there and
that's what we'll call it we'll say
that's a point that's a dot okay and you
say well i want to use the word point
well not if you're going to
say that what you mean by that is
location
and the the little the little spot
only represents the notion
the concept of point
of of uh location it's like saying i'm
gonna replace
love with a heart but yeah or
or the goodness in you with an angel
well that's cheating are you referring
to goodness or to the angel
are you referring to love or to heart
are you referring to
dot or location make up your mind if
you're gonna do
location call it location don't tell me
don't use words such as point and then
say well it's undefined
it's primitive you're primitive
you're a neanderthal if you do that okay
uh what have we
before us is a dot and a state that's
that's what
dot that's what point and line are okay
these are geometric figures
okay the the point and the dot that i
showed in fact let me put it up there
again i think it was this
let's see if we can get it up here no
wrong one ah
give me a second here here point in line
of 50.
let me put it over here okay that's what
i'm referring to okay so
uh what you see there objectively is a
dot
okay you want to call it point no
problem but that's what a point
is that's what we have objectively in
front of us
and what is a line is a stake that's
what we have objectively
in front of us okay these are geometric
figures
okay physics has no use for abstract
figures none of these figures have
anything to do with physics we don't use
these
we don't use the word point we don't use
the word line in physics
okay that's what we have in front of us
but we have no use for this stuff okay i
want to make sure that
that's understood as well we don't use
this we use real objects okay
and physics is about explaining
mechanisms
okay what the mathematicians call
philosophy or
semantics or beliefs or whatever they
call it okay
abstract geometric figures cannot be
used to explain
a single mechanism in physics that's why
we don't use any of these we have no use
for point because i cannot explain a
single phenomenon of nature using the
word point
this abstraction which is just a circle
or the 2d line which is just a stick
okay math points and lines can only
be used to describe okay which is the
itineraries and locations which they
call
point uh 0.09 right and so please
keep your locations and itineraries out
of science
you know if they want to use this stuff
i have no problem but don't bring them
into science don't bring them into
physics
we have no use for points and minds
that's just the introduction so let's go
quickly through the uh
stuff i went through the other day but i
have to go through this to get to
the taurus okay here's our circle what
was the circle just an itinerary bunch
of
dots what are those dots they represent
locations
so i shouldn't even be putting the dots
we should simply think of
that as a bunch of locations it's an
itinerary
in this case specific case it's an orbit
that's
all a circle is according to mathematics
because that's how it's defined
how is it defined the curve traced out
by
a point location that moves in a plane
so that the distance from a given point
is constant it's a point in other words
it's a location
circling a location called the center
that's what a circle is according to the
mathematicians
so we have no figure it's an itinerary
it's an
orbit okay let's get that through uh
because people didn't want to introduce
the circle when they want to do stuff
there no no i'm not going to let you
introduce the figure
because we have no figures in
mathematics they have no use for figures
okay what's uh what's the next one the
circle
okay uh i'm sorry the semi-circle
semi-circle what is it half a circle
that's all it is so it's the same
itinerary but stopped halfway
so what are we talking about when we say
semi-circle we're talking about a figure
geometric figure no we're talking about
an itinerary
half an itinerary of a circle
okay so a circle you could say is a full
circular itinerary the semicircle is
half of that okay that's what it is
that's how it's defined that's
and again if if it's defined it's a
concept it cannot be an object we don't
define objects in physics we point to
them
objects we point to because we can point
to an image and
concepts we define so if these people
are defining what a circle is what a
semi-secure is
uh they're turning that object into a
concept
and again it is a concept because
they're talking about itinerary so
no problem there okay and uh so what is
a
sphere well they get the semicircle and
they twirl it around
and they call that a sphere there's a
definition so you can
read that a little later on your own and
yeah that's what a
sphere is so what is a sphere is it a
ball
is this a sphere absolutely not this is
not a sphere
or this one better this is not a sphere
okay assuming it's perfectly smooth
perfectly solid la la la
it doesn't matter that's not what a
sphere is for the purposes of
mathematics because mathematics has no
use for
objects for this mathematics only talks
about the itineraries
around the sphere they can get rid of
the sphere
and they say i'm i'm going to deal only
with the itineraries
with the locations okay so let's get
that straight
i'm not going to let you we use a lot of
that one okay people want to say no no
here's a sphere this is what we do with
an there's no figure called
a sphere in mathematics in geometry
uh official geometry okay
um so one fellow asks
this question he says uh you forgot to
mention what a sphere is for you
well i just said it but even says it
it's a ball it's a solid figure
that's what a sphere is okay
so this one's not solid okay
you can see it's spongy assuming it's a
perfectly smooth
uh ball perfectly smooth
ideally smooth and then it's solid
completely solid made of a single piece
okay there's no space uh
in between there we're talking about
god's
ball sphere up there in heaven you know
it's a perfect sphere
not made of parts made of a single piece
perfectly smooth
that's that's the ideal sphere that's
the i the ideal ball
really that's what it is okay and so
that's what it that's what a sphere is
uh that's the
the notion we have a sphere is it an
object or a concept no it's an object
it's an object because it has shape
that's the only condition that needs to
be an object so it's not a concept it's
not an abstraction like people say
because they never define these terms
they don't know what a concept is they
know what
they don't know what an abstraction is
we had to define these words we said
look an
object is that which has shape sphere
has shape it's an object period we're
done
no more arguing okay another fellow says
the following
uh with regards to this topic he says
uh bill says circle is an object because
it has shape
yeah when it comes to a sphere it's a
concept because there is no perfect
sphere
poor folks purple hose no it's got
nothing to do with that does a sphere
have shape yeah it has shape so it's a
sphere is a physical object uh
is it um is it an ideal object yeah it's
an ideal so you can only imagine it
and you can talk about it but uh there
is no
real physical sphere out there
in the universe maybe god's sphere up
there in heaven you know
fine but no uh it's the mathematical one
that is a concept and it's a concept not
because it's got imperfections
got nothing to do with imperfections
it's got to do with the fact that the
um the sphere of mathematics
is the twirling of an itinerary
so it's not the notion that people
normally have what a sphere is the word
sphere in the minds of everybody if you
ask
anyone what is a sphere everybody will
show you a ball we'll show you something
similar to this they'll say well that's
a sphere
that's not what it is in mathematics
okay so we have to understand that that
we have a problem with the definition
the definition doesn't match
what they're pointing to they're
pointing to a ball and they say that's a
sphere
and then they use something else which
is itineraries
and it turns out that when they point
they don't even point to a ball they
point to a bunch of lines
that form uh you know some kind of
circular pattern there okay
okay so um
here we have uh the square that was the
next
uh geometry we talked about and the
cube what is a square well it's an
itinerary it's a perimeter
a bunch of locations around the fence
that's what it is
and so the square is what you see that
little dot tracing
all around that's what a square is for
the purposes of mathematics
of geometry okay and then what they do
is they take those
itineraries and they put six
of these itineraries these walls that
they think they built
and they say well now we built a cube
and so it is a cube it's a bunch of dots
or maybe lines and the lines are made of
dots and one of those dots those are
locations what are those lines a bunch
of
itineraries so a cube
the so-called cube is not a geometric
figure
also okay so let's start there because
we're going to be building our tesseract
with this stuff and
all we're talking about is locations and
people get lost in thought they think
now they're talking about figures
at no point in time are we talking about
figures
there are no figures in mathematics they
have no
use for figures they only have used for
itineraries
and locations but to give you the
misleading impression that they're
talking about figures and physics
they put something there that is visual
and they say well that's the point
what do you mean the point well yeah
what is the point well the point is
undefined see because it's this
little dot that we use to represent our
location
and what is the line well it's this
stick one dimensional stick
this figure that we put to represent
itineraries a bunch of locations and
then with this they're going to
construct their
cube okay so let's keep that in mind
let's keep the context in mind
we can't depart from this because what
they described does not match what they
point to
in this case they do because they show a
bunch of dots
is that a cube or
i think i've got it here
well now here they put it in motion
okay they put the cube in motion
right and uh
so with it what are they rotating there
well they're rotating locations
they're they're what they're doing is
moving time around
time and motion around okay and here's
one guy who uh
builds his cube okay and he tells you
how it's made he thinks he's putting
walls there
and again he's not showing squares
because those are not squares
a square is a sheet those aren't sheets
those are just
lines that he put there okay because
obviously it's got a frame
and the inside is different than the
frame then those are not squares but
this guy thinks he's got squares there
first of all
second he's gonna build he's gonna
construct
is that what science or what geometry is
a construction
of of how you constructed your your um
statue how you chiseled it
no in science we point to a cube we
don't construct it
but that's what these people do they
constructed piece by piece and they're
constructing it wrong because this
fellow
is trying to construct his cube with
uh these windows window frames
a window frame is not a square okay so
this is not only uh not a cube but
its constituents are not squares so
let's get that straight up front
this is not a cube and that's and those
are not squares
okay so he starts out on the wrong foot
and on top of that
he's constructing something we don't do
in physics for objects we point to a
cube
we don't construct it piece by piece and
say hey this is how i made it
i don't care how you made it well what
material did you use
i mean okay um
and so this file continues and now it
gets even weirder because he's gonna
make a projection of this
and that just uh what he's gonna be
doing really here
is is really uh building a hologram he's
gonna
shine light on the cube and he's gonna
look at the shadow on the wall
and you can see the shadow on the wall
does not match the cube that he's
shining light upon and that he's moving
around in that case
you can see that the edges of the cube
on the wall the one that's on the
screen okay you can see those edges he
calls them squares but they're not
squares
he's distorted them in in fact he says
that
they become distorted yeah no kidding
because he's not talking about squares
and one thing this fellow never learned
a lot i guess
all geometers never learned this is that
when you have a circle here's a circle
okay
and again this is a 3d circle okay
just so that people say oh but that's
not a circle yeah it is a circle
people understand here you have a circle
okay if i move it like that now i have
an
oval i no longer have a circle
so you can't move you can't tilt a
circle
or a square or anything here well i do
have uh
no i don't have it oh yeah oh let's see
if i can get this
assume this is a square okay let's just
assume
it's not it's it's a rectangle in that
sense right it's more rectangular than
squarish
but if i move this sideways
i don't have a square anymore okay
that's known as a rectangle so if i
started with a square so i mean it's
more or less like that
when i move it sideways i no longer have
a square you can't
tilt the square and call it continue
calling it a square which is what this
file did here okay
uh and again let me show you this i
think it's this one no
wrong one sorry let me get this one
you know that's not a square a bunch of
squares that's on the wall
in other words we don't have six squares
on the wall but this is what this guy
keeps calling them
and he does tell you that they're
distorted no kidding
and this is important because that's
what they're going to do with the
tesseract
and again people with tiny minds tiny
brains they don't pick up on this
for them it's all the same they say oh i
understood you didn't understand squat
let me show you
what these people have well let me let
me first go to this one
here's uh here's what a square is and
what a cube is for the purposes of
physics
what you see in front is what you get
this is what you ordered
that's what you got in the mail okay so
a square
there you see it uh
four equal sides okay that's it
and we don't build cubes with squares
we point to a cube we don't chisel it
little by little and say come back in a
year and i'll tell you what a cube is
now we point to a cube and say that's a
cube
and again it's a three-dimensional
projection under two dimensions because
again it's an ideal
figure it's perfectly smooth
made of a single piece and the only guy
who's got that is god
okay up there in heaven we don't have it
here on earth
so that's what a cube and what a square
are
okay objectively that's what's in front
of our eyes
okay important to understand all that
um so let's move on to the
tesseract because they're going to build
it also piece by piece
they can't point to a tesseract because
when they point to a test right we have
no idea what they're
what we're pointing what they're
pointing to and this is what they're
pointing to they're pointing to this
okay when they make it stand still
and well if you ask anyone to describe
it they would say well that's two nested
cubes that's what it looks like except
for the fact that they're united by
those
lines that connect their corners
and so what we have is a little cube in
the center
and then we have an irregular figure
you know on the sides of it and again
we're supposed to look at
or think of this in three dimensions
projected onto two-dimensional
uh platform background or whatever okay
but even in the best of cases if that's
a three-dimensional note in fact they
built some of these i've shown it the
other day
they built some of them and all the ones
that you see out there are
three-dimensional they have length width
and height
there is no other dimension it's
three-dimensional this is not a
four-dimensional anything
okay but the
folks in relativity they they're the
ones who use this
and they say time is involved with some
people also have
mental problems trying to understand
that yes time is the fourth dimension
folks sorry to
wake you up on that okay so what do they
do
well what they do is well first let me
show you
my version of this okay and here it is
that's what a tesseract is it's built by
a cleat cube that is growing through
time
okay and they take the first and last
uh frame of that film they superimpose
they
one upon the other they make a collage
and then
they start rotating that collage
and a lot of people had problems with
that they said oh bill
what do you say you didn't understand
well
uh here's uh first uh how they rotate it
okay in other words or what i'm saying
that they're showing there there's
they show a cube that's growing okay
they show the first and last
um frames of that film
they superimpose them then they start
rotating that film
that's essentially what they're doing
and yeah people say bill you didn't
understand you don't understand what
you're talking about
there's one guy let me put his comment
up there
okay people get upset
you didn't understand the idea of a
tesseract at all i'm not arguing that
it's an object necessarily but time has
nothing to do with 4d mathematical
geometry
we just showed that it does with 4
with 3 and with 2. with with
one even you know what is a line line is
a bunch of
locations it's an itinerary that's what
a line is
and you know if you're gonna make a
second
uh location and a third one
you're involving time sorry sorry to
break it to you
and if a line which builds up all the
other geometries above it
is an itinerary involving time
all geometries 100 of
the so-called figures of geometry are
made
with time all of them there's not one
but show me one that's not made of time
okay
so yeah these people have mental
problems
they don't understand this stuff and
they'll insist because
that's how they've been educated they've
been brainwashed
they've been hypnotized in high school
and caused to believe that they were
staring at geometric figures i'm trying
to clarify
to them that they're not staring at
geometric figures because they're not
defined as
geometric figures how do you make a
person who's been brainwashed to
like this fellow here to understand that
you got to break his head you know with
uh
my dough roller that's what he needs
that's what he really needs this person
has
again mental problems uh i'm not arguing
okay he says the time component of the
movie of the rotating warping hypercube
has as much to do with its shape as the
time component of the movie of a cube
rotating to show
its 3dness there are static depictions
of the tesseract yeah
no kidding they turn all that time
and you don't even know what you're
staring at that's your problem
you don't know what you're staring at
you think you're looking at a figure
because you know i'm staring at a
a stand-alone figure but that's not what
they defined
that's not that's not the that's not the
tesseract that's not the taurus that's
not the cube
what they're doing is moving things
around in front of your eyes
and they're showing you the last picture
they say that's a cube you say
okay i understand that it's a it's a
cube it's a geometric
figure it looks like the uh rubik's cube
right
no that's not what it is in geometry
it's a bunch
of itineraries only at the edges where
the lines you know that give it that
frame that's what it is that's all uh
that's all the cube is
and the cube is what they're going to
use to build what the tesseract so guess
what
not only do you have motion and time but
it's a bunch of
locations that's all it is and they're
going to be twirling these locations
around this
motion they're going to be moving around
they're going to be moving time around
so yes you are
wrong buddy sorry okay try to wake up
okay you're the guy who doesn't
understand there are static depictions
of the test right just as there are
static depictions of the 3d cube yeah
because you didn't understand what
you're staring at
the cube inside a cube uh
of a tesseract is not time slices
it's a projection uh what is a
projection we just saw a minute ago a
hologram
is that what it is is that what a
projection is a shadow on the wall
what is a projection see these people
don't tell you in detail what
what you're staring at what they
understood they're just saying you're
wrong bill
uh it's a projection well you didn't
tell me anything
okay so until you clarify what you mean
by projection
exactly are you talking about light
playing with lights
is that what a projection is a shadow
you block something uh from light and
you get a
penumbra or an umbra or whatever is that
what it is
completely irrational perhaps but in a
much different way than what you are
debunking well no i'm debunking the
right one you just don't understand what
you're staring at
okay another fellow says something along
those lines
it's important to address these
individuals so they
learn something perhaps maybe sorry but
there is no small
cube or growing cube in a tesseract and
none of tubes
none of the cubes are expanding okay so
you said bill you're wrong okay what's
right let's find out what
he proposes instead every side in that
diagram has the same length in
each individual cube cell has the same
volume as the
cube depicted in the center that's only
a description so far you haven't told me
anything you haven't told me what those
lines that connect the corners are
okay that's what we're trying to figure
out here okay now i'm saying it's time
you're saying it's not then what is it
okay why would your lecture you on
things you clearly don't understand
well because i like to talk about stuff
that i don't know anything about okay
okay another fellow says i think i've
got someone else yeah
well this is the following got to get my
dough roller on these guys
okay you say we can't have more than
three orthogonal number lines you call
dimensions because we
can't imagine them that is religion not
science
we don't imagine and believe we assume
and explain
okay oh he's right we assume and explain
what is it that he missed
i mean he got that right so far but he
missed something okay and that's what i
want to clarify here
what did he miss
this one
let me get it up here okay this sweaty
no wrong one sorry
give me a second here get so many of
these
one second i'll be there
there it is
this is what he missed okay put it side
by side
uh what he misses the criteria for
defining irrational the word
irrational what do we mean by irrational
remember this is rational science so we
had to define the word rational and
irrational
that no one in the last 10 000 years
defined they didn't define the word
rational because everybody thinks that
rational
is what he believes in and he who
doesn't believe like him
is irrational well that's a little bit
too subjective
so we have to create some criteria for
what rational
and irrational mean and these are the uh
criteria for irrationality
treating concepts as objects known as
reification concretization
using inconsistent definitions or
undefined words
theory is inconsistent with or doesn't
follow from the assumptions
describing especially mathematically and
claiming to have explained
and the last one which applies to this
fellow mechanism assumption
doesn't work or cannot be imagined
okay and so um the issue here
is you can make all the assumptions you
want but you have to imagine your
assumption
if we cannot if you're going to explain
to an audience and
the audience cannot follow what you're
presenting remember you have to present
the objects
in front of you and if you cannot
present a four-dimensional object you
cannot
present a fourth perpendicular
a direction to the three directions
known to man
then we cannot follow your presentation
because you don't have an assumption yet
okay so you can you you have to use an
assumption before you can explain and if
you cannot present your assumption which
is the case here
you don't have a case it's just that
simple so you lost buddy
sorry okay you lost right there because
you cannot present your assumption
your assumption is what's irrational we
cannot picture
the object that you're trying to present
and you cannot present three lines and a
fourth one in perspective and say well
that's the
fourth line in perspective now you got
to present an object
please present the objects and show that
that object
has four perpendicular directions
you got that that's what you got to do
so no it's not a question of belief
it's a question of is your assumption
rational
and objectively it's not so it doesn't
even belong to physics if
if you say that you've got a four
dimension four dimensional object
please show us the object that points in
four perpendicular or
faces in four perpendicular directions
mutually perpendicular directions
uh okay let's get to the tesseract here
let's see if we can educate some of
these bozos who
think they know what a tesseract is okay
here it is
uh this fellow he
has this ridiculous thing which he calls
the tesseract
what he does he's gonna build it step by
step he's gonna expand it
shrink it he's going to do everything he
can with it okay
very nice looks flashy first of all he
doesn't have
a cube that's a cube it's not a bunch of
windows
window frames so he doesn't have a cube
to begin with
okay and then he's gonna open it up
and he just does this out of his magic
wand
because where does he get those cubes
okay
they're not in there now and he just
pulled the rabbit out of the box
he's playing jack in the box he's he's
just pushing pulling out
a clown out of a box that's all he's
doing
and he's pulling out like eight
different clowns one this
direction one the other direction uh
what is the movie a thousand clowns
[Laughter]
with jason robots yeah
anyone can do that it's called magic
mathematics
okay uh and
what he does also he does a projection
okay well this is someone else but same
thing okay and they do what is known as
a projection
they're gonna take that uh cube and
again they're gonna tear it apart and
they're going to just pull
cubes out of nowhere you know they say
look i
pull the cube here another cube he could
pull 20 cubes out of there if he wants
to
i mean how did he do this and people
said well yeah i
understand i i know what he's saying
well you can't know what he's saying
because first of all he doesn't even
start out with a cube
none of those are cubes what you have
there is itineraries
itineraries for the line for the square
for the cube
and for the hypercube all of them are
itineraries
none of them are figures so this guy is
just inventing stuff putting it there
it's flashy and people just
gawk because they don't know what
they're staring at
what is that jesus christ the cross
this is nonsense this is pure nonsense
poppycock
has no no place in science
okay you got to be a mental [ __ ]
mental [ __ ] to believe in this garbage
i don't know how else to say it maybe
with dole roller behind
in the hand okay so yeah this is
absolute nonsense and only
mentally [ __ ] people believe and
pray
to the tesseract okay and most of them
are relativists
okay um here's the
hypersphere just in case covered it the
other day
so that we can move on to our taurus
okay
and what is a hypersphere it's just a
growing balloon that's all it is
it's a balloon through time and you can
see
that you know the balloon is small and
then it just gets bigger and bigger and
bigger that's all it is
both in the static mode and in the
dynamic mode
that's what all these figures are they
involve
time they involve time because each
point
that constitutes their sphere their
lines etc
their geodesics each point is a location
that's all we're staring a bunch of
locations
which are full they're fooling your eyes
by representing them with dots
and you say oh i know what it is that's
a dot no it's it's not a dot the dot is
pictorially representing a location
none of those are geometric figures
math has no use for figures geometry has
no use for figures
none of those are figures figure belongs
to physics
only math has no use for figures
okay so here we go to with the taurus
finally get to the taurus okay
hopefully people understood that all
so-called geometric figures of geometry
of mathematical physics relativity
specifically
are just locations and itineraries
that's all they are
nothing more okay no geometric figure
okay so we have
this we have a taurus that is a bunch of
locations
a bunch of dots what are those dots what
are they
they're locations so we're staring a
bunch of locations which are represented
with little dots
two-dimensional dots which you're
supposed to think of as zero-dimensional
dots
whatever that means okay that's what
you're staring at
so you're not staring at a doughnut
you're staring at a bunch of locations
and the only reason you can see those
locations
is they represented each location with a
dot
do we understand or not okay let's hope
it sinks in
some of the brains out there p brains
okay
so you're not staring at a donut you're
staring at locations that
somehow you know fool you into believing
you're staring at a donut okay so that's
a mirage
okay so here's your taurus but this one
is made a little differently okay here
goes
let's get it in there okay this one's
made with lines
okay geodesics they're called shortest
distance between two points again points
on a curved surface okay okay so we have
two different kinds of geo of
tauruses here one is made of points the
other one is made of lines
but not really that different because
remember the lines are made of points
so these two things are really identical
it's just that
they give you the misleading impression
in one case that it's made of points the
other one it's made of lines but
they're the same they're all made of
points okay so what is a taurus
well we gotta look at the definition so
that we understand where we're at
and here's the definition okay this is
the formal definition let me get myself
back in here
someone said to me there is no flowing
in or on a torus it's a shape a static
object absolutely not learn what a torus
is
for that you got to look up the
definition this is from the wikipedia
but you can find the same definition
there
everywhere okay here it is a taurus okay
is a surface of revolution
what is the surface of revolution have
you ever heard of that term
well if you if you took college physics
or
or at least perhaps even in high school
physics
a surface of revolution has to do with
calculus
okay with integration okay
uh for those who took that and they know
what i'm talking about okay but
forget about that just a notion what do
you think a surface of
revolution means is it overthrowing a
government is that what revolution means
no revolution means you're gonna rotate
it you're gonna do you're gonna put it
in motion you're gonna
build something by scanning by sweeping
okay that's what revolution means in
this context
generated by what revolving
you know you're gonna revolve this thing
around the uh
the circle you're gonna revolve it
around somehow you're gonna sweep
okay revolving what a circle in
three-dimensional space
about an axis that is coplanar with a
circle
so what is a taurus it's built with
circles
and a circle remember uh they said it's
just the
the outer portion it's just the
circumference that's the circle
according to
some of these bean brains you think a
circle is just the um
the little ring no right here they're
seeing a circle
they're treating it like this like
you know a a plain surface
completely continuous surface that's how
they're treating it here
and they're going to say that that
circle
you know which they call disk some
people call it disk
is going to sweep around and construct
build through time
ocean they're gonna build the famous
taurus
okay do we understand each other or not
this is what a taurus is it's a surface
of revolution
which revolves it's a circle that's
moving around
what is a circle a bunch of dots a bunch
of locations
and again there's two notions one is the
circumference and one is the disk
which one is the circle well we don't
know we'll find out someday
okay because they deliberately
uh have it uh ambiguous
so that you don't really know which one
is the circle is it the circumference or
is it the disk
so why do we need the word circle i mean
let's just talk about disc or
circumference right why do we need the
word circle
and yeah they put these uh
words in there and people get confused
and then they think they're staring at a
geometric figure
and they're just looking at a bunch of
locations they don't even realize this
okay and so what do they do next well
they do the weirdest thing you can
imagine and that's
uh you had that taurus right
which was swept around
by a circle right what they're going to
do next is he's going to put this thing
in motion they're going to twirl it
around they say oh the twirling's
the twirling donut or the taurus or
whatever
so they have the motion of the
of the locations that's what's moving
here
we have locations that are moving
all these locations are twirling around
they're orbiting
what are the orbiting the center which
is another location
all we have so far is motion we have no
physical object in front of us we have
no geometric figure
all we have is motion locations lines
water lines locations
what are circles locations it's all
location it's all motion
there's it's all motion time there's not
a single geometric figure in all of
mathematical physics
okay not even space time which we'll be
dealing with
okay okay so uh now you know what a
taurus looks like and how ridiculous it
is for these people to
say oh we're gonna twirl the the taurus
okay it is ridiculous because these
people don't understand what they're
doing
and they fool people through the images
and people say well i understand what
i'm staring at
no you don't it's a bunch of points
that's what you're staring at
locations okay so here's the conclusions
okay uh math figures are not figures
not a single figure in all of math
because math has no use for
figures okay math fizz only has
itineraries
line circle etc bunch of locations
all math solids are hollow there's not a
single solid
in all of mathematical physics in all of
so-called official geometry
um tesseract not equal to 4d it's not a
four-dimensional anything
no such thing as a four-dimensional
object
and relativity specifically states that
the fourth dimension
is time so when these people say that
the tesseract is a four-dimensional
object but it does not involve time it's
it's people who are mentally [ __ ]
people who have no understanding
whatsoever
of what they're listening and what
they're seeing they don't understand
what they're seeing what they're staring
at
so they are mentally [ __ ] and this
is what i
offer as a solution for those people
okay
tesseract is two nested cubes that's the
static image that's what you see there
you see a uh one cube inside another
that's it
and the fact that they built these
things
okay in real life i showed i should have
put this up there but
some people have built it with sticks
and legos and whatever they
they built two nested cubes and that's
what a tesseract is
objectively when you have a static image
just two nested cubes what is a
tesseract in real life the notion these
people want to
convey to you is that it's an expanding
q
and that's a concept that's not an
object that's not a figure
okay we're talking about at least two
objects the beginning and the ending
object that's known as two objects
two objects is the definition of the
word concept okay
hypersphere also not a 4d object it's
just a
balloon that's expanding that's all it
is what's a taurus is it 4d
because we have time right the taurus is
now spinning on itself
what are we talking about well we're
talking about time right hopefully we're
talking about motion you just saw it in
motion
so is that a four-dimensional doughnut
is that what you're going to tell me
i mean when you see it static you say
well that's static that's a
three-dimensional donut
fine how about when it's twirly now we
have motion now we have time
has the doughnut turned into a
four-dimensional object because now it's
rotating on itself
it's got time so again
a boy standing still he's
three-dimensional but as soon as he
moves
he turns into a four-dimensional boy
because now time is involved now you
have a clock to time him
this is the issue okay taurus bunch of
locations and itineraries that's all the
taurus is
and when rotating square cube tesseract
whatever etc
mathematicians are spinning motion they
are spending
time they are spinning a web
of nonsense of poppycock
okay okay
let's get on to some of the questions
and comments people made
okay oh
i had another
this is what we should do with people
who talk about tesseracts and so on and
think they are looking at a figure okay
this is what i recommend okay
what do you think what to do with mental
retards who construct figures piece by
piece
uh put them in stockade
yeah these are people who have mental
problems i mean if they can't understand
something
simple which is kindergarten stuff
really is for
kindergarteners uh i don't know i don't
know what to say
these people don't need a physicist they
need a shrink
they need a psychiatrist to handle them
okay here we go here are the
questions and comments but i'm going to
start here here's the case first against
anyone who proposes see or touch
as a criteria for defining the word
object for the purposes of physics for
the purposes of science
in ordinary speech yeah people think
that an object
and exists are synonyms and they
are things that you can see or touch not
so in physics in science we have to
define the word object which is very
crucial
because you can't do physics without an
object the golden principle of physics
okay so we need to define that word
object very very carefully
and it turns out it's very simple the
only property an
object has all objects in the universe
the universal property of objects is
shape form synonyms through synonyms
shape and form the same thing
in physics not in ordinary speech but
yes in physics
so you can't see your touch to cling on
that's on the other side of the universe
i already went through that here's a
picture of that let's put that up there
for those who missed it last time
here's our dear klingon he's a gazillion
miles away okay can you see his sphere
can you see
his cube his table
his dog his tree no you can't because
he's a gazillion miles away
okay so if you can't see or touch
his table his tree are those not objects
do they not exist because you can't see
or touch them
if you're blind then he doesn't have an
object
so yeah you can't use the seed touch
criterion
um because you know
we can't see or touch every object in
the universe okay
you can't see a circle you can see a
circle but you can't see the air okay
and you can see and touch a
request see and touch require a second
object you have to have the object that
does the seeing and touching
and so you can't define the word object
invoking another object
saying well i need another object to do
the seeing and touching
okay so that's another self-defeating
element of the definition of if it's
based on c
touch you can't say that you are going
to invoke an
object to define the word object another
object second object okay
uh then the other issue is it's
subjective did you really see the spirit
when you were high when you were drunk
when you were you know floating in the
air
okay and if you don't see her touch your
mama
today does she not does she stop being
an object does she stop
existing because you can't see her touch
her she's under she
she's in new york and you're in
california
hopefully uh you better have a better
criteria otherwise your mother
disappears okay
does she cease to exist and yeah the
only purpose of the c-touch criteria of
ordinary speech which the mathematicians
have
introduced into physics and into science
is to stealthily introduce technology
into science that's the only reason they
say let's go to the lab
okay and one problem with that is that
you know
you're not gonna discover
uh the invisible intangible objects
mother nature uses to do gravity to do
light to do magnetism by going to the
lab
there is no way you can run an
experiment to elucidate
the architecture of the objects mother
nature
uses to do her invisible phenomena
okay straightforward okay so the only
way to
see mother nature's uh invisible
mediators
is by maybe drinking a beer sitting back
and visualizing you gotta think
what object could mother nature be using
to do her
uh her stuff and you know it's very
simple like you know i
gave the case of um how a window broke
you know i use the case of a little
cartoon there from
felix the cat and so he throws a
horseshoe in one case a stone in another
or a brick
and he breaks the window well if if
if you don't see the the brick
can you imagine the brick going through
the window
can you visualize it even though you
weren't there to see it
with your own eyes you you asked the
question well how did that window break
well
let's see and you try to visualize
trying to imagine what could have
happened you said
it could have been a break you know
brick goes through the wind you can
imagine that
and with that you have explained the
mechanism of how the window broke
your theory another guy might say well
it was a dog that jumped through the
window another guy says no i hit it with
a crowbar baseball bat the
baseball went through the window you
know there are different theories out
there of how the window broke
but we can all picture all of them all
we have to do is make the invisible
object that we can't see anymore
we got to make it visible you're going
to make the ball visible you got to make
the crowbar visible you got to make the
dog visible
then we all understand what your theory
is of how the window broke
and gravity magnetism
light all these are the same there's no
difference all you got to do is make
visible the mediator
once you make visible the mediator
you're done
people will understand your theory do
they believe it
that's something else that's religion
belief is religion
right now we need to do is make an
assumption of what
mother nature could be using as a
mediator for light gravity
electricity etc the workings of the atom
okay um
i like to say this that the definition
of um the word object destroys all
religion
that's why people are up in arms against
this definition
because i it hurts them it hurts
it rapes their virgins okay they
believed in this thing because that's
what they were taught in college or high
school
and they formed their beliefs their
theories and then i come along and say
well you know the word object destroys
your religion
why because well the golden principle of
physics you can't do
physics without an object you
uh you physics requires an object that
means that
you got to present an object to do
physics and for that you need to define
what an object is and you can't use the
definition of ordinary speech because
that is absolutely wrong
irrational meaning that you need to
touch or see it
and yeah we can point to essentially
that's how we
uh designate an object in physics we
present it you can point to it you
people can see it and they know what
you're referring to we're done
and you just give it a name x that's
object x there i point to it okay it's
got shape we're done
that's how simple it was kindergarten
stuff and concepts we define
okay we don't point to concepts you
can't point to love you can point to
heart
but not the love that's why the
definition of the word object destroys
all religions okay
okay so let's continue here
the issue people raise uh two things
specifically one is observation the
other one
is um prediction
they think that prediction and
observation have something to do
with science okay that's what they've
been taught that's what they memorized
in high school in college
and that's what they repeat because
that's what they've been taught
that's what they learned that's what
they memorized then they learned it
through authority
okay and so the issue is the following
word you see the word observation in the
scientific method
right there okay science rational
explanations
do you see the word observation anywhere
in there
that's a scientific method so if you
don't see the word observation you don't
see the word prediction either
okay then we're done you can't say that
observation is part of science you can't
say that prediction is part of science
because
you don't see it in there you don't see
the word or you don't even see a
provision for it even within those words
there is no provision
for observation or prediction
so where did you get this notion that
you need observation prediction in
science
please justify it okay
and if you say well i don't agree with
that definition of science
good uh
get in the ring and fight for your
definition let's see if you can defend
your definition of science let's see
let's see what your science is all about
i'd like to hear it okay uh
and i'll be bringing my dough roller
[Laughter]
yeah and there is a
an issue there with uh with prediction
let me let me put it up to you so that
you can see where i'm coming from with
this prediction issue um let's say you
predict
that tomorrow there's gonna be an
eclipse
okay two o'clock
205 exactly it turns out everybody looks
up at the sky
205 and there's an eclipse you were
right
and people say oh what a genius he was
able to predict
that there was going to be an eclipse
okay he probably figured it out because
he's been
following eclipses for the last 10 years
and he discovered that
an eclipse happens every 10 years after
so much time
so much so many minutes so many days etc
right
and he knows exactly he calculated what
the recurrence is
when the when the thing happens again
and again and again
okay so he calculates that he can tell
you he can predict exactly the
date time and minute and second it's
going to happen
and everybody says he's a genius look he
can predict when it's going to happen
when the eclipse is going to happen
the question is does he know why
there is an eclipse
what causes that eclipse is it the same
thing to predict and say
it's going to happen at two o'clock in
the afternoon
and why well because it's happened like
that every 10 years
and so i know it's going to happen again
that's a prediction
but you don't know why what causes
that eclipse to happen
so what is science the science doing the
prediction just calculating saying well
i measured and
every measurement comes out the same so
give me my no
or is science saying what caused
understanding what caused what causes
an eclipse to happen
so this is this is why prediction has
nothing to do with science
it's explanation that makes you burn
some calories up here you have to
explain
the cause and for that you need objects
you have to explain a
mechanism that's where you got to break
your brain
but to say that you calculated uh
because you
by experience you realize that you know
the eclipse happens every 10 years
okay so we give you a noble for that
because you you found a uh a uh
recurrent uh theme something that
happens over and over again you just
spotted then
calculated that is that what what
science is about
so no neither observation or prediction
neither neither one of those uh have
anything to do with science
and again they're not part of a
scientific method
okay um here's a i think a fellow
asked the question
says the following one of the few
intelligent folk out here at least came
with a
very interesting question i liked it uh
since we don't
use antonyms as definitions instead of
defining
space as that which doesn't have shape
would it not be scientific to define it
as
that which is apart from shape or maybe
that
which or maybe that which which contours
shape okay uh which has been used as the
definition in previous lectures or maybe
just plain
nothing can we use the word nothing and
say space is nothing
could space be the concept of possible
locations
could it be the concept of contrast in a
single
object okay well first of all he's
proposing something
that's good he's not saying bill you're
wrong
you got it wrong you're irrational uh
i'm proposing something
in the alternative that's that's the way
people should debate
not say you're wrong and then just close
the door behind them which is what
all these religious folks do this guy is
proposing something in exchange
now let's find out why all his proposals
are i'll call it wrong they're really
irrational
okay and let's find out where the
inconsistencies
where the inconsistency lies okay
so let's show this let's put it side by
side okay
and these are the problems with what
he's proposing first object is not a
synonym of
shape shape is the universal
property of objects okay shape is what
an
object has it's not equal to
okay the antonym of space is not shape
the antonym of space is object
okay so space is not an antonym of shape
and neither
is object a synonym of shape
space is an antonym of object nothing is
equal to space
so you can't use the word nothing to
define space because nothing
is a synonym of space and a vacuum
and then we can't use the word location
because location needs to be defined
uh after we define the word object
okay you need an object to have location
what is location
the set of distances from all objects to
the one uh in in question the target
object right and so um
you you need to define the word object
before you define location
and uh with that you have the antonym
which is space so you can't talk about
location
until you define first space and object
okay and then um you also must define
he said could it be a concept well no
because you must define the word object
before defining the word concept
concept is a word that invokes embodies
two objects
okay or two words treated as objects so
those are the reasons you cannot use any
of his proposals
and we're going to stick by shape some
people say bill
can you define shape for us we don't
know what shape means
again it's the devil's advocate
extreme devil's advocate we don't define
shape we don't have to define shape
you say oh you need to define these
words no no we don't define
every word in the dictionary okay that
which has shape that's the
that's the word object why do we not
define shape well first of all we don't
define every word in that sentence
i mean is it easier to define the word
that
how about the word which you think
that's easier than you find in shape
that which has shape how about has
to have the verb to have oh man that's
that's a monster
is it the same to have 10 pence 10
pennies in your pocket that
have an idea
are those the same thing those two haves
are those words any easier to define in
the word shape are you gonna
banter me on answer why didn't you
define the word which
how about the word have now we don't
define every word in the dictionary to
please
the devil's advocate because we will
never please him because what he wants
to show
is that all definitions are circular
because you're going to need to define
the words you need to the the words that
are used to define another word and then
you got to define all of those
and that takes you through the whole
dictionary we don't do that in science
the way we do it in science we have to
distinguish
the we have to have a definition for the
word object for physics
sorry we can't spend our life going in
circles through the every word in the
dictionary
to define the word shape okay
and so that's what the idiot i call them
idiots of the
of the uh uh devil's advocates
uh want you to do they want you to they
want to show you that
they're gonna they're gonna destroy any
definition you put out there because
you're gonna need to go through the
whole dictionary
that's what they're trying to do and
they're not going to be successful
because the issue is another one
and this is the context but people with
tiny brains
cannot figure this out they really have
a mental problem
okay a very serious mental problem
and this is the issue the issue is that
when
we define the word object we have to
distinguish which what the
idiots of mathematics have which is see
and touch
and shape do you know the difference
between
c and shape do you know the difference
between
touch and shape because if you don't you
need to see a psychiatrist
that's the issue the issue is that you
got to compare shape
against the other criteria that are used
to define the word object
we can't leave the room until we define
the word object because we can't begin
to do
physics unless we have objects and
unless we define the word object
so you can't say well i'm going to take
you through the whole dictionary bill
no way we don't define every word in the
dictionary we need a criteria for the
word object
and that word is shape if you don't know
what shape is go to kindergarten
you know or
little uh what is it or elementary
school first grade
and they'll tell you what shape is okay
maybe you skipped uh going to
kindergarten maybe you
skipped going to elementary school and
that's why you don't know what shape is
we learn those
when we're four or five years old so if
you don't know what shape is then you
got a serious
mental problem and the issue there again
is not the
fine-tuned definition of the word shape
irrelevant totally irrelevant
what we need to know is the difference
between shape and mass shape and volume
shape and touch shape and see
we need to distinguish between the
criteria that we're gonna use to define
the word object
that's the issue right now we don't have
a definition for the word object and
that's the one we need for physics
okay we don't need the word shape for
physic we need the word object
shape is a property of an object how do
you tell this to
mentally [ __ ] people people autistic
people who suffer from down syndrome
okay so yeah you can't take
us through the whole dictionary it's not
going to work uh you can you can go
alone through the whole dictionary
through every word in the dictionary we
don't have to do that
not in science yeah okay and
i think this is the final issue here
final question final comment
fellow says
he says geometry is a branch of
mathematics
no it's not a branch of mathematics at
all
it's half and half in fact there there
is no science called mathematics
mathematics is a language it's known as
hieroglyphics
okay that's what mathematics is just a
bunch of symbols that represent
concepts so mathematics is a language
like chinese is a language like greek is
a language
and to some you know mathematics is
greek to them okay
but geometry includes the science known
as physics
and the language language known as
mathematics
okay figures uh belong
exclusively to physics okay so
the figure belongs to physics and it
turns out that geometry doesn't use
figures at all you use well
itineraries math has no use for figures
math only uses locations and itineraries
and i'm talking about official geometry
as well what's being taught in
high school and college okay possibly in
elementary school
um math deals with measuring and
calculating
okay which are totally outside the
bounds of physics
in physics we don't do calculations we
don't use math at all we don't use
equations
in physics we have to explain okay
we have to explain mechanisms we have to
explain how mother nature does gravity
we have to explain how mother nature
does magnetism we have to explain how
mother nature does light electricity
the workings of the atom that's what we
have to explain we have to explain the
mechanisms
once we figure those mechanisms out
we're done with physics
forever there is no more physics after
that we have
figured out how mother nature and father
universe and god and the devil
run this place this world
so all we have to do is figure out the
mechanisms and we're done there's no
more physics after that no more science
all we have after that is technology
and descriptions mathematical
descriptions right now we only have to
figure out
how mother nature does these invisible
tricks
that make our world work and for that
you only there's only one way and that's
visualizing the invisible intangible
mediators
okay and then the circle belongs to
physics
okay and the value of the circumference
radius etcetera belongs to math so if
you want to calculate the area of a
circle which is not a circle which is
just a circumference according to some
okay just a ring okay well you
multiply pi you know 314 times
radius squared and it gives you the area
that's got nothing to do with physics
that's
calculation has to do with math it's a
relation
uh a ratio
okay that's all it is and it's just for
calculating areas
to get a number is that science no
that's a language that represents in
fact it's
tautology that's all it is science is
something else it's explaining
mechanisms as it relates to physics
and with that i'll see you on wednesday
we'll see